der gang schon der erste ton schuhe aus
recyceltem gummi zumindest die sohle
besteht aus abfällen der
niederländischen hauptstadt amsterdam
die 23-jährige ökonomie studentin soraya
minara ist begeistert von der idee und
sichert sich beim verkaufsstart eines
der ersten 500 paare
sie sind sehr bequem ich mag die farbe
und besonders die sohle mit dem
stadtplan von amsterdam
der stadtplan ist in die sohle
eingraviert schließlich stammt der
rohstoff von eben diesen straßen
er scheint eine art erneuerbare
ressource zu sein
1500 tonnen kaugummi werden auf
niederländische straßen gespuckt jedes
jahr dabei vergehen 25 jahre bevor
kaugummi biologisch abgebaut ist ein
problem für jede großstadt
[Musik]
wir müssen viele leute bezahlen um die
straßen zu reinigen kaugummis sind ein
großes müllproblemen wenn man auf die
straße schaut sieht man überall kaugummi
die menschen nehmen es gar nicht mehr
wahr aber wenn man sich darauf
konzentriert sieht man dass es mehr
kaugummi als straße gibt um auf dieses
problem aufmerksam zu machen ließen die
macher des gam zu 250 kilogramm kaugummi
von den straßen der niederländischen
metropole aufsammeln
check hier ganter vom amsterdamer
modelabel explizit er entwarf das design
hilfe bei der verarbeitung des kaugummis
gab es von der britischen recycling
firma gam drop für den designer eine
spannende herausforderung
wir mussten erst einmal ausprobieren ob
es funktioniert wir sind schließlich die
ersten die das material nutzen
aber es ist sehr innovativ und man kann
viel damit machen die idee für
alternative recycelte materialien ist in
der schuhbranche nicht neu die spanische
firma penny atex hat eine vegane leder
alternative aus ananas blättern
entwickelt auch aus fisch leuten die
sonst im abfall landen würden wird leder
hergestellt
das deutsche label name fertigt daraus
unter anderem schuhe
[Musik]
und der sportartikelhersteller adidas
hat eine ganze schuhkollektion die aus
ozean müll produziert wird ganz nebenbei
kann durch solche projekte für ein
bestimmtes problem sensibilisiert werden
wir hätten auch eine werbekampagne
machen können schmeißt keine kaugummis
auf die straße aber das hätte nicht
funktioniert
das klingt wie eine mutter tue das nicht
und da hört niemand zu aber mit so etwas
kreativen wer einem turnschuh bekommt
man eine ganz andere aufmerksamkeit und
vielleicht denkt jemand beim nächsten
mal an den schuhen schmeißt seinen
kaugummi nicht auf die straße der schuh
passt damit perfekt in den nachhaltigen
lifestyle der sich bei jungen
großstädtern immer mehr durchsetzt
sneaker aus alten kaugummis sind dafür
ein ideales statussymbol
[Musik]
sie sind neu
sie sind knallig sie sind nachhaltig und
damit absolut instagram wie man schon
wenige stunden nach verkaufsstart sieht
[Musik]
ganz billig ist der kaugummi show jedoch
nicht 200 euro kostet das paar
ich finde den game show innovativ weil
er durch upcycling die straßen von
amsterdam ein bisschen sauberer macht
ich denke es ist der beste weg um junge
leute zu erreichen
mit einem coolen projekt auf das problem
aufmerksam zu machen
so erreicht man auch die jugendlichen
die die kaugummis einfach ausspucken
stylische schuhe die im besten fall
helfen die straßen ein bisschen sauberer
zu halten
[Musik]